привіт проходить вставай парад камера
добра можемо абаджян від править я сергей
з місця син фар apple республіка крим
випускник національний університет уфе
сухого не це спорту в каїві бив
оборонні камери сидить на вас до 100 і
знайшла проти за духом то перспективи
кар'єрного зростання головне було
вступати в українські вище складно я
щитами ніхто треба допомагає атак а
вступати в гру 100 ви че інфу сайту
доступного свято і мся справа прибрати у
програми не розкривши друг і все було
просто диму подарунок частки
нещасним шанс я сказав з-під їжу
вище за переселенця то спочив з ходом
харчованого корейському університеті
яблуко причастя на радіо заходиш там
мовлячи себе своїм серцем анни білу
ворону
так ореш на шановний а для мої будні
студента
[музика]
вас тут чекають